in the space of just a day a major
escalation that few had expected
hamas rockets in the skies outside
jerusalem
for the first time since 2014.
one is confirmed to have hit a house
another was intercepted by the israeli
missile defense system
to the south in gaza the hamas militant
group released a video claiming to show
the rockets being launched
in all more than 40 were fired most into
israeli communities in the south of the
country
and this an anti-tank missile from gaza
the israelis say it hit a civilian car
one person was injured the situation
is and how quick in jerusalem mid
broadcast the airaid sirens were
followed by distant thuds
quite a few explosions uh in the
distance here in jerusalem
extraordinary and and here you can see
here cheering from palestinians
predictably israel was quick to respond
and hard
disturbing images from gaza show what
hamas says is the result of an israeli
airstrike
with three children among the dead
with the closing moments of a day which
had begun in the heart of jerusalem's
old city
in the shadow of one of islam's holiest
sites running battles
palestinian worshipers at the al-aqsa
mosque say they were provoked by israeli
police
[Music]
whoever started it the site of israeli
stun grenades inside the mosque
was a provocation in itself
outside the gate we watched injured
taken away there were more than 300
wounded by the end of the morning
some of cases have been transferred to
hospital in some cases little
fertilization is still there
the times the israelis prevented medics
from getting access to the wounded
and with no explanation
clashes were always to be expected on
today's confluence of events means that
it is extremely tense with the worst
clashes that we've seen
for quite a few years and so now the
prospect of another prolonged conflict
with the palestinians
some people are talking about a third
intifada
the third intifada starts
yeah it will be continue after ramadan
by late evening in gaza the pain of all
this
images which will embolden and enrage
the israeli retaliation will continue
for many hours
probably days mark stone sky news in
jerusalem